est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
vous en tant qu'homme politique suisse
quels sont les avantages et des
inconvénients de votre système dit de
votation des savanes ont adopté de
votation à l'initiative ou de référendum
le référendum c'est la critique en live
du de la population parce qu'elle n'est
pas contente sur une loi ou une décision
qu'on aurait pu prendre ce qui nous
évite aux excès parce qu'il faut se
rappeler que dans notre gouvernance on a
un consensus politique qu'on a souvent
des forces de droite de gauche et du
centre qui travaillent ensemble dans
tout excès et éviers immédiatement
sanctionnée l'initiative c'est des
propositions il ya des problèmes de
société
modification de la constitution c'est un
droit qui est donné depuis une vingtaine
d'années et qui parfois peut nous poser
des problèmes on a eu des migrations de
deux masques qui a été été décidée car
il ya des conséquences à que nos
relations avec l'europe et des mises en
applications parfois pourraient être
douloureuses l'avantagent c'est quoi
c'est que les suisses ont l'impression
d'être associés à la vie politique du
pays
je pense pas que le citoyen pense qu'il
associait le citoyen est associé bien
souvent d'ailleurs les personnalités
politiques sont sont des miliciens on
m'a pas j'ai un travail de 50% plus de
mama charge me chargeant berne et la
quasi totalité des représentants
politiques ont plusieurs plusieurs
des activités qui leur permettre d'être
peut-être plus à même d'apprécier là la
tendance si on la met à fait comme ça
qu'on est pas coupée de la population
c'est ça on peut l'être on peut l'être
parce que le rouge comme tout de suite
un dès que vous prenez des
responsabilités par nature vous pouvez
changer le pouvoir peut changer la
personnalité est-ce que aussi une
votation ou initiative populaire ça peut
également fédérer un peuple qui au
départ très hétérogène non je crois que
c'est baiia de rejeter comme on
l'appelle
on l'a vu parfois sur certains thèmes
parce que c'est clair que le latin une
appréciation différente d'autres parties
de la suisse c'est vrai que est en berne
déjà depuis un certain nombre d'années
je connais que la suisse centrale sur
bien des thématiques a les mêmes
préoccupations que la suisse latine
et puis dans la région zurichoise région
bâloise région de l'équipe de l'économie
quelque à son affaire je crois que c'est
aussi notre mode vie économique voir
aussi notre patrimoine géographique qui
nous fait des différentes réactions par
rapport aux prêts de société mais cette
barrière de rösti certes elle existe il
faut la marginaliser est ce que on a
l'habitude de consulter les suisses
allaient dire sur tout et n'importe quoi
oui c'est ce qu'ont ce qu'on peut qu'on
peut entendre on peut le synthétiser
comme ça finalement c'est le citoyen qui
décide si on a un certain nombre de
signatures ben finalement nous sommes
appelés à nous prononcer et en fait
vis-à-vis des initiatives au parlement
on a la possibilité de faire un rejet
sec et sonnant ou soit dire ce thème de
société est important et on propose un
conte projet donc vis-à-vis l'initiant
on propose quelque chose
oda et le cas dernièrement par exemple
sur sur 2,2 m a même niveau là en terme
d'aménagement du territoire la
construction de pistes cyclables va être
puisse préserver au même titre que le
piéton
j'étais personnellement des initiants
tous partis politiques confondus et on a
négocié avec le conseil fédéral on a
trouvé un accord et on a trouvé la
solution ensemble et c'est la meilleure
des solutions en tout cas pour nous pour
construire ensemble les prendre bien en
compte les différences de chacun est ce
que quand on consulte le peuple on ne
risque pas quelquefois tomber dans du
populisme ans alors ce concert c'est
aujourd'hui un certain jeu quand on voit
la belle initiative qui sont lancés
dossier de là
qui peuvent parfois nous nous pose un
grand problème on a eu dernièrement une
votation sur l'obligation pas de deux
points nomination mais est-ce qu'on doit
subventionner ou pas les matches qui ont
des cornes
voilà donc ça va quand même relativement
loin ça aurait pu faire sourire certains
si cette initiative est passé voilà donc
un débat parce qu'au départ elle est
très sympathique une vache sans corde ça
peut interroger un mois la subvention
qui est donnée interroge aussi parce
qu'elles savaient des conséquences
directement sur les subventions dans le
monde paysan
voilà donc cette interrogation est
intéressante et elle doit être traitée
comme telle est ce que à force vous
constatez qu'il y à une baisse de la
participation à ces consultations
l'heure n'est relativement stable
globalement je précise parce que des
fois on a moyen que des fois on ne peut
plus ça dépend bien sûr de nombreux
thèmes parce que parfois on peut voter
sur trois initiatives pendant le
week-end donc à certains thèmes qui
attire plus que l'autre mais en moyenne
on a entre 35 à 45 % de taux de votants
sur tout les votations sachant que vos
votes au minimum quatre fois par année
au niveau fédéral et puis on rajoute
encore les élections locales qu'elles
soient communales cantonales
donc on vote souvent mais on essaye en
tout cas en tant qu'autorité de de
mettre toutes ces votations les mêmes
week-end puisque les citoyens
il adore beauté il adore donner bien sûr
leur avis il faut aussi respecter leur
attention est ce que les partis
politiques aussi pour vous c'est pas un
outil pour vous faire un peu de
propagande de temps en temps sur des
thèmes qui vous tiennent à coeur
ou alors juste avant des élections
histoire de mobiliser un peu tout le
monde
écoutez je crois que tous les partis
tous les pays sont les mêmes
on constate par dans la dans la vie
politique des thèmes qui ressurgissent
alors même que parfois on a déjà la
solution au niveau constitutionnel ou
même au niveau législatif mais ça fait
partie de la vie et c'est le jeu quoi on
va revenir sur un point vous dites que
quelquefois donc des décisions qui sont
prises par les gens en votation sont
difficiles à appliquer au niveau de la
loi pourquoi maintenant des thèmes de
société on pense l'immigration de masse
aujourd'hui il ya un phénomène qui
existe un jeu dire le réchauffement
climatique la problématique de la saison
excusez-moi l'immigration de masse des
suisses se sont prononcés contre
l'immigration de masse et tour un quota
du nombre d'étrangers qui travaillent en
suisse et et après vous en tant que
législateur vous avez du mal de
concrétiser ça dans la loi ben on a
essayé d'expliquer en son temps qu'on
avait des accords internationaux dans
les accords bilatéraux nos relations
commerciales avec l'europe la notion du
libre échange de savoirs des
conséquences on a sans aucun doute été
mauvais en son temps pour donner les
réponses à notre population est
aujourd'hui en dhr se trouve devant un
dilemme c'est nos accords bilatéraux qui
sont remis en cause par l'europe parce
que
le libre échange et est un point
fondamental imposées par l'europe voilà
il s'éteint positions fortes de la part
d' europe créent parfois aussi des
problèmes tout simplement en interne en
disant que l'europe nous impose des
règles alors même que nous mêmes on a
signé ses propres accords donc c'est
difficile pour nous personnalités
politiques à montrer les conséquences
qu'il pourrait y avoir de dire oui et
sans aucun doute on a raté le coche de
pas faire de contre propositions est ce
que ce sera ma dernière question
actuellement la suisse n'est pas dans la
communauté économique européenne à cause
ou grâce à une votation
alors le débat a commencé il ya déjà
maintenant plus de 25 ans 1
et dans lequel il ya eu des craintes ont
été exprimées par une personnalité
politique zurichoise emblématique
puisque son leader est même devenu
membre de l'exécutif pendant pendant
pendant quatre ans et il a il a sauvé
une thématique importante aux yeux aux
yeux de la société et qu'ils avaient
refusé notre entrée dans la communauté
européenne
voilà et depuis c'est un débat et
conséquences qu'on est là aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on constate qu'à une
bureaucratie relativement lourde de la
part de leur passé sans aucun doute
construit trop trop vite aujourd'hui
même ceux qui étaient pour cette entrée
dans l'europe le refuse mais préfère des
accords bien bien ciblés au lieu de
rencontre entre aidants dans cet accord
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
vous voulez le beurre et l'argent du
beurre un peu vous les 6 par rapport à
l'europe
je pense que peut-être avant avant lui
avant bien d'autres pays aujourd'hui qui
s'interroge sur la présente dans
l'europe c'est de se faire imposer par
quel quelques personnalités non non élu
parce qu'en fait ces deux élections
indirectes que vous avez et ça c'est
vrai qu'on est très très attachés quand
même la nomination de nos de nos
décideurs et la suisse s'est construit
avec 26 cantons 26 projets parfois
parfois différent ils se sont réunis en
somme en acceptant ce sont ces
différences et ce respect de l'autorité
est important faut bien savoir que nos
pouvoirs politiques fédérales il est
donné par la base c'est pas c'est pas la
berne fédérale qui impose c'est vraiment
le pouvoir politique fédérale
il y vient de la part des régions et des
cantons c'est comme ça que la suisse
s'est construit c'est comme ça qu'elle
continue à vivre vous cache pas qu'au
fil du temps de plus en plus les grands
projets de société se discute au niveau
fédéral mais dans la chambre que je
représente la chambre des cantons
il ya vraiment une attention très
particulière à ce que l'autorité locale
reste là où elle est et elle soit pas au
niveau supérieur bref au niveau de la
capitale de la paix intérieure
vous conseillez là au français de
prendre un modèle type référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
dis moi j'ai pas de leçon à donner non
je la décentralisation telle qu'elle
avait été voulu en son temps et dont on
sentait des prémices en à mon avis est
sans doute une bonne chose parce que la
sérénité régional est très important
lancé nécessite bien sûr des pouvoirs
institutionnels mais c'est aussi
nécessite aussi
des moyens financiers conséquents parce
que c'est clair qu'on ne peut rien faire
sans sans moyens financiers et la partie
critique on a aussi c'est que le plus
riche donne aux plus pauvres donc une
gré caution financière qui doit être
trouvé 200 jalousie bien au contraire
pour garantir l'unité nationale et ça
c'est très important et ça se construit
pas en deux minutes et en pensant qu'il
ya ka et ça va aller tout seul c'était
une grande histoire et j'espère qu'en
tout cas en skicross à la france que
cette histoire se fasse dans la sérénité